I don't need a sword because I'm the
doctor and this is my spoon Android's of
Sherwood I'm not gonna lie going into
this one I was a bit nervous the
historical set episodes generally don't
really do it for me they've been a
couple of good ones Vincent and the
doctor the girl on the fireplace but
most of the other ones have been
middling too boring for me they tend to
be the ones that fall into the most
predictable patterns and also deal with
the most cliches in terms of the setting
and the historical figures that turn up
and the funny thing is this episode kind
of does that same thing but it does it
to such a deliberate extreme that it now
suddenly works Robin Hood is so on the
nose and he is such an over-the-top
cliched version of what we all believe
Robin Hood to be that it just makes it
fun and it helps sell it and it really
helps that he annoys the ever-loving
heck out of the doctor I mean there
isn't really much more to talk about in
terms of plot other than that the doctor
takes Clara to Sherwood Forest because
she wants to meet Robin Hood he says
Robin Hood doesn't exist they
immediately run into Robin Hood and the
doctor could not possibly be any more
annoyed by that fact and as I said the
actual Robin Hood just from the look to
the performance just everything it is
the quintessential cliched stereotype of
Robin Hood but it that is actually
perfect for this story and for his
interactions with the doctor especially
Peter Capaldi continues to just own it
I'm just loving his his orneriness and
just sort of back his first instinct is
kind of just to argue with people and
you know there was something that I
forgot to mention last time but it was
brought to my attention again right at
the start of this I loved the new
additions and the TARDIS
I loved the chalkboards I loved the
bookcases if these homey little touches
that I think the the redesigned TARDIS
really needed because when they first
did that latest redesign that we got
introduced to in the snowmen I was kind
of like it's a little cold it's a little
sterile but you stick the bookshelves
and the chalkboards in there and now it
feels lived-in it feels homey it feels
right for this doctor absolute
Clara works fine for me and this she
keeps doing her thing and I'm kind of
the same place with her that I usually
am is like she's fine she gets the job
done I can't get invested in her I don't
know why at this point she works better
in this episode than when she's having
to mine deeper more emotional places not
that you know the actress is somehow
incapable of doing that but Clara works
best when she's fun and this is an
episode that is just fun especially
because those episodes can actually be
really tricky and darkbrew because they
tend to come off as very superfluous and
like they don't matter but because we've
kind of gone back to the earlier
template for how a series is gonna go
that we sort of got these standalone
adventures we just a little hints that
you are going to get drawn together
later in this case the promised land is
the hint as opposed to a much clearer we
are covering a series long story arc
which we got the last few times now
those sorts of stories are great I and I
love to those series but it did mean
that when they insert an episode into
those that was just there to be fun
it felt absolutely completely
superfluous it felt like fluff whereas
you go back to say the first four or
five series of Doctor Who it was okay
for episodes to be fun because then
weren't banking as much on a series long
story arc and since we're going back to
that for this go-around that means that
this fun episode just gets to be fun I
mean there wasn't really much more to
say to it beyond that this isn't a deep
emotional drama we didn't dig into new
layers of the new doctor or Clara of
anybody we didn't get much farther with
the you know the little nuggets that
we're getting as to what will be tied up
at the end but that's fine this one's
there to be fun it's fun now as I said I
tend to not care too much for the
historically said episodes myself I
mentioned the couple that I like what
about you what is your favorite Doctor
Who historical episode it can be from
the new series heck it'd give me from
the classic series there's some good
ones there Thai warrior still stands up
whatever your thought is on the matter
drop it down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned